hi I'm Erik Bosse and BlackWidow
revealed exclusive trailer footage at
Comic Con with Marvel Studios Hall H
panel announcing major details about the
movie's story and what this next
upcoming film in the MCU released in May
2020 will look like a story that
explores Natasha Romanovs past touching
on some long-running MCU mysteries and
gives us a peek inside Nats head before
everything in there was splattered on
Vermeer some really wanna guess you
don't want to know anything about the
bike what a movie and I predict anything
too right never ends your life so just a
quick recap on what we know so far in
this Black Widow movie joining Scarlett
Johansson as Natasha Romanov will be
Florence Pugh as the Elena Bulova a
rival sister figure to Natasha
in the comics Elena is an enemy KGB
assassin who hunts down etosha hoping to
take the title of the Black Widow away
from her it's these two characters who
appeared in the trailer footage shown at
Comic Con here's what attendees saw it
starts with the Red Room flashback
imagery from age of Ultron Natasha's
dark memories of her youth her training
and brainwashing into a deadly KGB
assassin then the footage showed scenes
of Natasha from The Avengers and from
Civil War there's the key moment she
switched sides and helped cap and Bucky
escape betraying Tony Stark over this
she narrates that all these events gave
her a family and that she has made
mistakes then after the Marvel Studios
title card we jumped to Budapest
Natasha ascends a spiral staircase and
arena room gun drawn she says I know you
know I'm out here want to talk like
grown-ups
then Yelena Bulova appears and the two
are locked in a standoff elena backs
into the kitchen then fistfight kitchen
gets wrecked Jason Bourne slash Kill
Bill a Natasha tries to hold her down
and gag her with the towel Yelena tosses
are over knife gets pulled out and then
the fight spills over to the living room
where the two women try to choke one
another with a curtain but then the
fight ends they catch their breath
Natasha calls yo Lane Assist and they
have a drink then follows an
action-packed montage motorcycle chases
gunfights running through the streets
jump through windows black widows line
for the first Avengers movie plays his
audio I got red in my ledger I'd like to
wipe it out and then we see the villain
taskmaster an image of whom was revealed
recently in concept art taskmaster takes
shots from Natasha and blocks them and
then after the movie's title card the
two fight on a bridge at night mirroring
their moves
exactly
now I'm sure we'll see this footage soon
in trailer form but the symmetry tells
us a lot about this movie story first
Natasha's relationship with Yelena
Bulova while in conflict with each other
in their comic histories enemies it
appears that the two have some kind of
sisterhood products of the same tortuous
upbringing pretty similar to Gamora and
nebula said video showed red haired
blonde haired women on a motorcycle
together suggesting that perhaps their
Budapest mission will bring them
together on the same side the villain of
taskmaster is an interesting choice in
the comics taskmasters Tony masters but
note that they've cast Rachel Weisz as a
character named Melina now Melina could
be a nod to Melina vistacal aka the
villain Iron Maiden for the comics who's
an anti Black Widow mercenary who also
has her roots in the Red Room but also
throw out there that it is possible that
Marvel could be considering combining
those two characters so that Melina
could also be taskmaster with their
parallel training and explaining why she
would be so precise at mirroring her
attacks showing Natasha reflecting on
her decision and civil war is also
interesting because apparently the
timeline of this movie is that it will
be set after the events of Captain
America Civil War but presumably before
Avengers infinity war meaning sometime
between 2016 and 2018 this is the period
when NAT was on the run after switching
sides from team Iron Man blocking Black
Panther so that cap and Bucky can get
away and then turning away from Stark to
live a life on the run with Steve Rogers
in this off-the-grid period presumably
around the time she decides to try out a
short blonde cut some exploit will
trigger the memory of a past mission the
mysterious Budapest episode that came up
between that and Hawkeye and endgame 10
years before that in the first Avengers
movie and it sounds like the Budapest
story will take place an earlier time
period a flashback to the pre Avengers
era maybe in the mid 2000s when Natasha
would still be an adult and this could
mean Hawkeye could make a whole cameo in
this movie as well as Nick Fury who did
mention Budapest as one of the places he
was stationed during the Cold War
meaning he still might have a safe house
or contacts there Belfast Bucharest
Belgrade Budapest I like to be a second
make him ride also joining the cast is
David harbour playing Alexi maybe a nod
to Alexi Shostak of a KA red Guardian a
Russian and super soldier counterpart to
captain
America Oh defect Bentley is playing
Mason and Ally from Natasha's priest
she'll pass to mark Lee endure and actor
Ray Winstone has been cast in an unknown
role to me it looks like this Black
Widow movie will be an espionage
thriller kind of like the Jason Bourne
movies but also like Captain America the
Winter Soldier which also featured the
hero confronting their past in the form
of a friend turn foe brainwashed into a
killer over the USSR and calling it now
I think we're gonna learn exactly why
Natasha dyed her hair blonde in that
period between Civil War and infinity
war yes she was on the run and probably
need to adopt new hairstyles and
disguises but perhaps the hair color was
also meant to honor an old friend a
blonde that she's still after all these
years beloved I'm sorry now when it
comes to this movie I will say it's a
bit odd that black widows first solo
film the film to launch phase four would
be a retrospective eulogy for a dead
character with no future in the MCU now
perhaps the idea is to introduce you
Lena Bulova as the new Black Widow and
the purpose of this whole film is to
kind of pass a torch on to the next
generation now if so I'm not sure why
they would need to pay Scarlett
Johansson millions and millions of
dollars who be in that kind of movie
when they could just you know put up
some dead Iron Man style Banksy's around
like they did when they pass that torch
onto Peter Parker and far from home but
sure as for whether a Natasha Romanov
could be resurrected on Vermeer like
psmith said that when cap went back to
return the soul stone would there be an
exchange
unfortunately the endgame screenwriters
seemed to shut down that idea Captain
America comes back with the soul stones
of war mirror that dude is on top of the
pasta again do we get Natasha do we get
Black Widow back
[Applause]
my dog no return I don't know what
listen that is not the intent the Intel
guys yeah I went over me guys should the
Black Widow title be passed on to a new
name like killing the Bulova or should
Marvel try to find a way to bring back
and natasha romanoff in the future MCU
comment down below with your thoughts
follow me on instagram and twitter at EA
boss and subscribe to new rock stars for
more breakdowns of everything he needs
to know about the Marvel Cinematic
Universe thank you for joining me and I
honestly think bring her back is the new
danger worse and ever things are worse
than ever
[Music]